foreign
Minneapolis Minnesota is where David
awaits David how can we help
hey Ken and Rachel thanks for taking my
call uh so calling for kind of how to
have a financial conversation with your
significant other
um so my girlfriend and I have been
seeing each other since the beginning of
the year have been dating most of that
time and I understand that finances are
one of those big ticket items uh that we
definitely need to be on the same page
before I put a ring on it hahaha
um we had one a few months ago and we
shared a few a few things uh
specifically our our overall debt number
and I could tell that she was very
uneasy and uncomfortable and probably
felt some shame and uh so we were
dealing with a lot of other things so
I'm like hey let's put put this
conversation on the shelf and we'll
address it later uh and we've been fine
since then with uh regarding that and I
just would like to hear your thoughts on
how to have that conversation uh how to
enter in that conversation how to have
boundaries uh do we need a third party
uh to help uh mediate that conversation
how serious is this gal for you
uh pretty darn
are you guys even talking about marriage
so uh not yet
um but that's because she is like we
have agreed not to do any like
progression forward uh because she is in
her first year of uh residency and
that's a very taxing year and I'm on the
uh I'm on the uh the the uh idea of uh
engagement should be three to six months
and we're not even near that um all
right like that time frame that time
scheduling frame I I don't know what
Rachel's gonna say but that's what makes
this show fun uh I I think that I would
be talking to to her about
uh General uh thoughts about money like
what do you think about debt last time
you kind of talked about here's how much
debt I have and then she told you how
much she had you felt like she was
shameful about it and all that kind of
stuff but that's not talking about
philosophies and this is really about
philosophical thoughts about money which
is something what do you believe about
money what do you value what do you care
about
um I don't want to have debt I would
like to pay off all my debt once I pay
it off in my marriage I don't want us to
do that I mean you don't have to talk
about marriage per se but just talking
about your views and thoughts about
money and I'd start there hey I'm just
curious what do you think about this
this is what I think about money this is
what I believe about money
does that hit you the wrong way what do
you think I'd make it all about you so
you don't put her on the defensive and
then you're gonna lay out your values on
money and I would see how she reacts to
that is she just asking legitimate
inquisitive type you know I mean just
I'm just getting to the bottom of what
you believe uh or does she have some
sort of problem with it but Rachel I
kind of stay there it seems to where
they're at in their relationship I
wouldn't go much deeper than just
putting your values out and seeing how
she reacts to it yeah because regardless
of her number of how much that she has
with if she's in residency and she took
out medical bills or medical debt or
sorry Medical
student loans to go to medical school
there's probably going to be a lot but
regardless of the number that's not a
reason not to marry someone but a
different value systems that's your red
flag and that's what Ken is saying and I
think that that's what's wise is to have
these overall but you guys how old are
you guys
uh so I'm uh 34 and she's
um uh 39 or 29. okay so y'all are I mean
at the age you're not like 18 or 19
where it's like the word marriage could
scare us if you guys are at the point
and as adults that you know if you're
dating for a significant period of time
for the well I guess in my head it's
eventually going to go somewhere so what
do you think about this is what I wanted
to know because the female opinion
versus the male opinion do you do you
sense anything where she said oh let's
just not Advance the relationship until
I get through year one I had a little
red flag but that's coming from a dude's
perspective that's why I'm putting that
out there do you see a red flag I I know
that it is a taxing it is a question but
I think that there's a lot of things in
life that are very taxing and I would
want to do it with Winston as my husband
okay uh so I would like him to have this
conversation I know I want your opinion
on this I'd like him to have this
conversation about money sooner rather
than later yeah and I would say it's one
of those conversations along with other
conversations of values so yeah having
the values conversation on money hey you
know when I what I see in my life in the
next three years is being married and
when it comes to money I want to be able
to have you know no debt pay it off if
um my future spouse who's you're my
long-term girlfriend so that's probably
gonna be you like uh yeah paying off
debt living debt free being intentional
to our money having goals uh all of that
is a value of yours David and then you
know kids there's another big
conversation on kids uh in-laws sex I
mean like oh like these are Big life
conversations that you have to have
before marriage and money yes is one of
them and at the top of the list like you
said David because it does cause a lot
of tension so making sure that you guys
have the same values but also David can
I just can I say this I don't know you
oh I'm very excited but I I kind of
think you just need to kind of just
relax a little bit oh I do too much
it's a three to six month window of
Engagement I was like yeah why what what
what what what a crazy world David would
you just say let's go to the courthouse
we've been dating him month all right
we've been dating a year and let's just
go right I do think you've got things in
a box and I can tell you that life
rarely fits neatly into the box I could
not hurt your feelings David what do you
think
so the the the the the uh the window of
Engagement is that's how long I think
engagement should be
um three months if if you if uh three
months I think is on the shorter end of
Engagement six months is longer
asterisks you know circumstances seven
months so I know I talked to her about
that while we're at it I'd add that one
to the list yeah yeah
um and so and I'm fine waiting but
um like I'm fine waiting what's another
six months or so
um and I know that she doesn't have a
whole lot of bandwidth because of
residency is very very taxing yeah I
want to plan a wedding and all of that
so I get that yeah yes 100 and I want
I want to like
um take as many things off her plate not
necessarily put make more things on her
plate like these more
um in-depth conversations but no no no
that's a cop-out I'm gonna tell you that
right now that is not putting more on
our plate you need to figure out you're
very serious about this and I get it I
love a man with a plan I love a man with
an opinion but you need to find out if
you guys are on the same page
um and I sooner rather than later she's
not too busy that she can't have the
conversation that Rachel's well yeah and
because these conversations too David
they bring a level of depth to your
relationship you get to you know her on
a deeper level and so that's not adding
more to her plate that's actually like
loving her really well and wanting to
know more of who she is and that so like
to me that's a real that's a
relationship that's not
um yeah that's not adding more to her
plate that's that's being a significant
other in my opinion I got a bad feeling
oh no kid I really do this is not a
relationship show uh but I'd love to
have one uh because if it was I would
say my friend uh we need to have this
conversation and everything else pretty
darn soon feels like you may be getting
the Heisman Trophy stance coming at you
a little bit and she's blaming the cut
the school and the it's a lot okay or
David's gone on really tough and he's
like tell me how much debt you have and
she's like you're making my thank you
yeah he could be a little too intense
maybe she needs to breathe a little bit
that's right so if you're three to six
month engagement rule so maybe too much
for her I don't know it's interesting
stuff have the conversation sooner
rather than later all of them David
embrace it